hey guys it's Justine and today we're
unboxing the new Apple home pod yes here
it is I'm so excited about this so you
guys know that I'm a huge Apple fan but
I also love smart home tech anything
that can help me simplify or control my
home especially through my voice I'm a
huge fan of so let's get to the unboxing
now we've got a great little pull tab
here so I don't even need a knife I even
brought a few selections for today but
it looks like I'm not even gonna need
these after all guess I'll put this away
okay round because you gotta see this
here it is
it looks so good
it fits my aesthetic perfectly it smells
it doesn't really have a smell
looks like we've got some little
instructions oh this is fantastic
they of course included a wonderful
Apple sticker here and it has a circular
little cutout connect your Wi-Fi and
turn on bluetooth hold your device into
the home pod and then complete the
on-screen setup all done now simply ask
Siri to play music to learn more go to
the tips set up your app I love this
extension cord
unlike most Apple cords and cables it
more like that plasticky finish whereas
this is sort of like a soft kind of
fabric you feel Siri
welcome to the iJustine household you're
gonna love it here Kate's plugged in
something's happening
hi hello okay oh it's happening it's
happening so it's asking me if I want to
set up and yes I do now it's asking me
where is the home pot bathroom bedroom
dining room garage hallway kitchen
living room master bedroom office patio
and I guess I'm just gonna choose office
for the sake of I'm in my office right
now so the next screen is personal
requests allow anyone to use this home
pod to send and receive messages and
reminders create notes and more with
this iPhone when it's connected to the
same Wi-Fi network so you do have the
option to turn this off so potentially
your friends could troll you and send
and receive messages on your Siri home
pod but I'm gonna enable it I'll take my
chances terms and conditions yes I will
agree so the screens the accounts and
settings screen so basically what's
gonna happen here is you're gonna be
using your iCloud account Wi-Fi all of
the settings that you have on your phone
to configure your home pod hi I'm Siri
welcome to home pod you can't tell but
I'm waving to get my attention say hey
Siri hey try it
Siri hey Siri what can you do hey Siri
what can you do I can do lots of things
like turn on the lights give you a news
update and tell you about the weather
now you try say hey Siri play some music
hey Siri play some music okay here's a
personal radio station built just for
you
starting with Third Eye Blind remember
any time you have a question just say
hey Siri
I love this song it's almost like she
knows already hey Siri stop playing I'm
gonna get a copyright strike so I gotta
be really careful hey Siri play me some
top nineties rock playing some 90s rock
oh hey Siri what is this band this is
EMF this track is called unbelievable
hey sorry when was the song first
released unbelievable by Jana came out
on May 7th 1991 Alexa stop playing oh my
god oh my god no
hey Siri stop playing it was a mistake I
didn't mean to say it I didn't mean to
say I'm so sorry to offend you
one of the upsides to home pod as
opposed to other smart devices as this
has a six microphone array so basically
it can hear you from very far distances
or even while the music is playing there
is a lot of tech built into this little
guy that we don't even see it features
seven horn loaded tweeters right down
here at the bottom and at the top is
actually where the high excursion woofer
is that is where you're getting the
crazy awesome bass at hey Siri do I have
any new messages you have two new
messages from Nick the Proterra digital
touch message that's my proof of life
yes what do you want to say I'm texting
you with my voice using the home pod
right now I am texting you with my voice
using the home pod right now ready to
send it yes
hey Siri text Jenna is Eric and tell her
that I am sending her a message from my
voice on the home pod you replied to
jenna ezarik Friday and says I am
sending her a message from my voice on
the home potted someway sister I have a
little fried egg emoji next to her name
so that's why I said jenna is Eric tried
a do I have a new message you have three
new messages for me Oh what are we on
for tomorrow
and rosy cheeks would you like to apply
yes we are still on for tomorrow to do
some cooking videos well let's tell you
if I'm laughing or not and it says no
yes we are still in for tomorrow to do
some cooking videos hey Siri turn the
volume all the way up that's very loud
are you sure yes turn the volume at half
this is great I'm having the best time
hey Siri stop playing play me some music
okay let's press play sharing with sound
monsters just press the volume down you
can do that just like that so it's crazy
about this isn't matter where you put
your home pod it learns your space so in
real time it is processing the
environment and what it should sound
like so no matter where you are in this
room because of the speakers that are
all around it you don't have to just be
standing directly in front of it if I
were to place this in the middle of my
room it would sound exactly the same no
matter where I was standing so the way
that this process is sound is different
depending upon where you place it
because this right now is close to this
wall it is real-time configuring each
speaker to give you the best listening
experience I am still so shocked turning
this thing up all the way there's no
distortion at all
turn the volume all the way down Wow
that scared me
height after the button this is also
touch sensitive so if you do press down
that will activate Siri so she is
listening right now as you can see I
don't have that information you press
down that bill yep though I was talking
to my friends hey Siri stop playing this
thing's fast it's really really fast
it's kind of difficult to give you guys
a listening experience because everyone
is listening to this video on different
speakers or different systems so there's
really no possible way that this is
gonna sound the same if you actually
experience it in person I'm gonna just
tell you it sounds so good well guys I
just wanted to do a quick little
unboxing for you so you can see what's
inside the box and how to get this thing
all set up plus a few of my favorite
features I love that you're able to
actually have a conversation with Siri
hey Siri
when was the song released weight of
living part 2 by Bastille was released
on March 4th 2013 2013 I think that's
when I actually interview them as MTV
event I did so the home quad obviously
does work best with Apple music and
that's because Apple has all of the
information about these songs in their
database but that doesn't mean that you
can't play anything else from Spotify or
anything else from your phone with that
you'll just have to use airplay okay
I'll pick office Juby Pharma so that's
great hey Siri what song is playing this
is called scared to be lonely by Martin
garrix when was the song released scared
to be lonely by Martin garrix was
released on January 27 so there's a lot
more that you can do with home pod and
I'm gonna go over that all in a separate
video but for now this was the unboxing
and a quick first look at the home pod
honestly I only was going to get one of
them but now after seeing it and playing
with it I definitely am getting more
later this year there will be a software
update to allow you to use two of these
and give you surround sound hey Siri
play me some party music sure here's a
personalized station of party songs I
had imagined oh yeah
Calvin Harris haha she knows me so well
hey seriously
to stop cleaning well thank you guys so
much for watching my unboxing video I
have another full video testing out more
of the features of the home pod once
you're done watching this which is right
now because this is the end of the video
go check that one out I'll put a link in
the description and annotation and a
card and I think you can figure out how
to watch it I'll see you there
[Music]
[Applause]